Paul Finebaum covers the SEC like nobody
else he joins us now Paul help me with
this Tennessee situation who does
Tennessee think that they can still get
I'm not sure Dan they have blown this
about as badly as I've ever seen and
that's saying something when you
consider watching coaching searches as
you know you can pull out any cliche you
want there they're very difficult to
watch in real time but in this case
Tennessee has made critical mistakes
from the beginning the fans thought they
were they were going to get Jon Gruden
which you and I both know they were
never going to get and then they waited
several days for Dan Mullen and he slow
walked them and ultimately chose Florida
and Greg Schiano was the backup choice
and I agree with everything you have
said the only thing I fault
the athletic director for not being
aware that that was a potential problem
and from all indications he caught him
off guard which I think led him to
completely overreact what happened
yesterday in real time on social media
is about as embarrassing as anything I
have seen in relation to at least a
college sport I realized there's there
are many other more egregious things
that have happened on social media but
several people began this campaign
against Schiano
by propagating the Penn State situation
and what was even more distasteful is
that several state representatives
without doing anything new just jumped
into the fray and started tweeting at
the athletic director and then students
showed up because hey there was nothing
else to do on the day on the Sunday
after Thanksgiving and and before you
know it Greg Schiano his reputation was
it was tattered and torn and shattered
and Tennessee backed out yeah I don't
want to hear a politician involved in
this
III don't and I and I feel bad for
Schiano who I don't know he wouldn't
have been my first candidate my top
choice but you know I and I don't know
how you vet this though Paul that all of
a sudden this new athletic directors
hadn't been on the job for a year is
gonna go you know what just this rumor
innuendo hearsay throwaway line you know
how many years ago
that Penn State is gonna come back and
haunt me by hiring this guy I mean I I
gotta be fair to curry I don't I don't
know if he had an you know obviously
blindside I don't know how he could have
seen this coming
no well that's fair but but at least be
aware that that there's a potential
issue with Schiano and be prepared for
it and no one know what the facts are
and by the way if you if he knew - he
knew yesterday what we we know today he
would have probably said you know what
I'm gonna grin and bear it
I'm gonna bring this guy and I'm gonna
explain it and I've you know
knowledgeable people explain that this
is this was really overdone but instead
he came in and and that's that's
probably the saddest part of them and
and and I think what it says is if
you're the next man up you're going do I
want to work for this guy and and I
think that's an issue that it just I
said let me let me come to the altar and
confess my sin so someone who does a
talk show where a lot of this goes on I
don't want to act like I'm a virgin here
this is not news to me that that fans
can rise up but I I just don't like the
way it was done it was done maliciously
it was done as an angry mob and and I
really by the way I went to school at
Tennessee not that that matters but but
it's something that you know I care
about like anyone would care about their
alma mater and I really wonder what the
future is because quite frankly the last
10 years have been a total embarrassment
and and I'm not sure what the next
couple of years look like after this
what about tmartn it's actually a pretty
good idea you know he's he he
quarterback Tennessee to its last really
good day in college football winning a
national championship ironically tmartn
came in and won the championship the
year after Peyton Manning left which is
something that it's a footnote or maybe
a final jeopardy question
but you know he's at SC you know he has
not yeah there's always been some
distance between T and the university
but at this point he would be a good
choice I'll throw one even more bizarre
it would it would it doesn't even seem
that strange today yesterday would have
seemed like the the upset of the
millennium but Lane Kiffin is not a bad
choice either
okay sure why not before well it's
amazing the sins you can forgive if
somebody's talented and a you know Lane
Kiffin knows offense and you got to have
offense in the SEC and sure will look
the other way with with Lane Kiffin
coming and we're talking to Paul
Finebaum of the SEC network Paul
Finebaum show okay couple other things
here where do you want to start with the
other coaching changes here how
surprised were you Chip Kelly said no to
Florida and yes to UCLA not very
surprised and you know I think Jeff
before I've seen Jeff every Sunday in
Bristol so I've gotten to know him a
little bit and he consistently and
constantly talked about fit Dan and
knowing the Florida culture and knowing
Chip Kelly I didn't see those two going
hand-in-hand I think he realized that
pretty quickly
Florida is is a pressure cooker on a
similar level as Alabama if there could
be such a thing and you know three of
the last four coaches there have failed
Urban Meyer is the only one who has been
successful since Steve Spurrier and I
think knew that UCLA is a much quieter
job
you know after Floyd and Dan Mullen was
at best third choice for Florida behind
chip and Scott frost but he knows the
terrain and he was there during the last
glory days and that's when Tebow and
urban were there yeah I think UCLA makes
more sense for his personality plus you
only have to beat a couple of teams in
the pac-12 to get a chance to play for
the national championship and if you're
trying to go through the SEC it's pretty
tough sledding so I think he looks at
that he knows the landscape
he knows the schools he knows the
coaches he knows the recruits I think it
makes a whole lot of sense there Jimbo
Fisher leaving Florida State I know he's
reunited with the athletic director at
A&M if that happens but man leaving
Florida State I understand the surprise
but Jimbo nearly left two years ago to
go to LSU he was part of that that Qunu
table that almost threw over through
less miles at the end of the 15 season
and he backed out
at the very last minute and I say this
because Jimbo is quirky and and I think
the marriage at Florida State has seen
better days and even though there has
been a lot of success not this year I
might add I think that he's been looking
to get out of there it's difficult to
get out of there though because that is
such a really good job Texas A&M is it's
a money pit quite frankly I mean there
is just so much money that could be made
there and I think there it is also a
school that I've always felt could be
the next Alabama it just never has been
and I think Jimbo knows that as well and
sometimes you just need a change we all
know that there's no need to tell you
how does Alabama get back into the
national title picture they need they
need they need first thing they need is
Ohio State to win and they just have to
hope it's not overly impressive because
it would then come down to Alabama and
Ohio State and you know if TCU upsets
Oklahoma it becomes an easier path but
if it take its if it's a flat Ohio State
Alabama
competition then Alabama
Alabama's overall resume doesn't quite
add up but they have one loss to Auburn
rural Ohio State we were terrible at
home against Oklahoma and it looked even
worse on the road losing by 31 to Iowa
and I think that's what they have to
hope for they don't they don't get the
13th datapoint down by winning the
conference championship and Ohio State
fans need to be careful what they are G
for because last year they were arguing
the exact opposite against Penn State
where Penn State won the the Big Ten and
Ohio State hockey and without having
played for the championship so how's his
play out in the SEC Auburn and Georgia
rematch yeah I might give a slight edge
to Georgia today I mean that may sound
silly but but Auburn at home is
different than Auburn anywhere else and
and I do think that the Georgia is a
really spectacular team they just did
not execute three weeks ago in Auburn
but you know I also wonder kick can
arbitrarily play knee better than they
did Saturday against Alabama I don't see
how well they they did against Georgia I
mean
that it that was pretty impressive what
they did to Georgia well yeah I mean but
they they have put two of the all world
performances in a really three week
period now they can maybe you need to
get them on Sunday Night Football
your job is too easy Paul you have so
many storylines really it is it is right
it just Dan yesterday yesterday I was on
a plane trying to keep up with all this
and I've never seen anything in a two
hour flight from Hartford to a North
Carolina be anymore a bizarre and I've
covered this league you know about 135
years and and and yesterday I mean it
surprised even or curmudgeon like me how
how fast things could change
I'm always great to talk to you Paul
thank you Dan a pleasure
that's have Paul Finebaum for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]